et livrés et affidés actuellement
conjoints de fait célibataire je suis
marié conjoint fr conjoints de fait
célibataire le trois quart des couples
sont mariés au pays mais le nombre de
couples en union libre augmente
le canada arrive au premier rang pour ce
type d'union parmi les pays du g7 est ce
que vous comptez un jour vous marier ou
pas du tout
probablement aucune idée moi pas la
nécessité
c'est tout québec au nunavut et dans les
territoires du nord ouest que la
proportion de couples en union libre est
la plus élevée autre constat le nombre
de couples ayant au moins un enfant a
diminué il ay à 50 ans il était de 64%
il est aujourd'hui de 50 % le
recensement c'est juste comme une photo
instantanée des cop la dengue sont
encore jeunes ont pas encore une fois
d'avoir leurs enfants et d'un autre côté
le découpe âgées dont les enfants sont
déjà parties et pour la première fois
statistique canada comptabilise les
données sur la diversité de genres
1,5 pour cent des couples sont de même
genre ou contre une personne transgenre
ou non binaire
pour ce qui est des revenus des
canadiens ils sont en hausse partout au
pays à l'exception des province de
terre-neuve-et-labrador et de l'alberta
à montréal le revenu médian des ménages
après impôt est de 65 mille 500 $ de 85
mille dollars à toronto et de 87 mille
dollars à calgary parmi les dix plus
grands centres urbains du canada les
villes de québec et de montréal ont les
revenus médians les plus bas les revenus
médians du québec sont un petit peu
supérieur à ce qu'on constate dans les
provinces de l'atlantique
mais ils sont intérieurs par exemple
revenu médian en ontario en alberta
l'aide financière durant la pandémie a
aussi eu des impacts sur les inégalités
financières
le nombre de ménages à faibles revenus
avaient diminué en 2020 ici ma isabel
rochât radio canada montréal